Wilson saw government as a  problem-solver as problems change  government has to adapt and so people  should be free to adapt their government  to whatever problems it was at the time  that they wanted the government to  address from the point view the founders  certainly they wouldn't have disagreed  with Wilson that people have to make of  government what what they think best  what the founders would have said was  that we're all however governed by our  human nature that our Creator gives us a  certain nature and that brings with it  certain permanent truths about the human  condition that we have passions that may  be a danger to us just as well as we  have reason which gives us the capacity  for self-government and so while we're  free to do with government what we wish  were not we're not able to free  ourselves from the basic law of human  nature which binds us all as human  beings